lined up next week for the plenary in
Strasbourg a dense agenda with tax
evasion terrorism assassination in
Russia credit card fees and the fight
for equality among the key unties monday
kicks off with the first meeting of the
special parliamentary committee
investigating member state tax rulings
for multinational corporation it all
started with lux leaks but the scandal
spread to belgium netherlands and
ireland citizens want answers mep s have
six months before the committee folds to
come up with proposals for tackling the
issues king abdullah the second of
jordan will be addressing plenary on
Tuesday last month his country reeled in
shock after a fighter pilot was captured
by extremists from so-called Islamic
state and burned alive Jordan is taking
part in the international coalition
strike force against Isis the theme
continues on Wednesday with a discussion
on terrorism ahead of the meeting of EU
heads of government and state in
Brussels later in March the fallout of
all this in Europe comes under the
spotlight the same day on Wednesday when
mep s discuss anti-semitism Islamophobia
and violent extremism events in Paris
and Copenhagen in recent weeks make this
an increasingly pressing issue on to the
assassination of the Russian opposition
figure and former deputy prime minister
but East Nemtsov gunned down the shadows
of the Kremlin any piece will be
discussing the killing and the state of
democracy in Russia with high
representative federica mogherini on
Tuesday also coming up in debates on
Wednesday growth unemployment and the
social impact
within Europe's economic policy
coordination framework known as this
semester and on Monday a debate on
progress on the campaign for equality
between men and women in EU this for
2013 the blindingly obvious conclusion
there's still plenty more to do finally
good news on the horizon for Europe's
retailers worried that already tight
margins are being squeezed even more by
credit card companies charging them high
fees each and every time you and I use
our cards Parliament will be voting on
Wednesday to put a ceiling of 0.3% on
most card companies there's agreement
among member states and it could come
into force within six months well that's
it some of it enjoy the week